les droits de l'enfant souvent bafoués
on l'a vu cette semaine encore en france
avec plusieurs faits divers dramatiques
viols tortures séquestration alors même
que lundi l'onu à adopter la toute
première convention internationale
chargée de définir et de régir ces
droits pour hélène dorlhac la secrétaire
d'état à la famille qui intervenait tout
à l'heure au sénat au colloque de
l'association pour le développement des
droits de l'enfant la maturité des
enfants des années 90 leur permettra de
faire respecter ses droits
la preuve à ce même colloque autant que
les spécialistes des groupes de petits
enfants ont donné leur avis sur cette
convention patrick convention sur le
droit de l'enfant
article 1er au sens de la présente
convention
un haut fond sur le temps de tout être
humain âgé de moins de 18 ans les
enfants avait des devoirs
depuis l'adoption de cette convention
l'enfant est devenu une personne avec
des droits celui d'être nourri éduquer
protéger informer mais aussi celui de
pensée bien sûr de jouer un texte qui
leur donne le droit de vivre l'enfance
désormais la parole est aux enfants et
ils ne se sont pas privés de critiquer
ou d'apporter leur vision et leurs
espoirs
c'est un à l'enfant de s'exprimer
librement
à ne pas être maltraités et puis a
changé beaucoup de choses hein mais
faudrait que aussi les autres pays
acceptent de la signer c'est pas
toujours facile de dire à mes parents
que qu'on évolue et que leur montrer que
maintenant on est gros mais que font
qu'on peut prendre sur nous cette
convention ne réglera peut-être pas mais
fera progresser justement port du voile
islamique notamment
il faudrait qu'il y ait deux conventions
une plus pour les adultes et la deuxième
pour les enfants car je pense que celle
qui avait là était un peu trop difficile
pour les enfants les enfants et son
maître julien pas de leur faute si à la
guerre celle des adultes et ils ne
doivent pas être mêlés au conflit
ils veulent empêcher doit gagner son
argent de poche d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui
prouve que ces graisses ne sont pas en
train de donner un coup de main à leurs
parents les droits de l'enfant est alors
c'est quoi mes droits papa alors article
au sens de la présente convention un
enfant s'entend de tout être humain âgé
de moins de 18 ans